[Music]
my defense team was very adamant about
making sure that I was able to have a
fresh start
after the trial
I didn't receive any help or assistance
from my biological family
I was given a little bit of money from
my defense team to start to get on my
feet
they're not just my legal team but my
surrogate family here
I found a little apartment just north of
my house downtown by Pat McKenna was a
lead investigator during my case
I've been working for Pat McKenna as his
research assistant for 10 and a half
years
okay so I guess we'll make a file and
print out give me two seconds and I'll
see if I can word search the document
and find it it's worked a lot of cases
over the years it's the whole reason I'm
doing what I'm doing now to pay forward
everything that was done for me
I spent the last 10 and a half years
doing primarily criminal defense work
because I don't ever want to see someone
be pigeonholed by not only law
enforcement but the media he railroaded
like I was
foreign
[Music]